ce n'est ni sur la nationale 7 ni à la
porte du garage que nous allons
retrouver charles trenet maison palais
des congrès à paris où le grand charles
s'est installée jusqu'au 21 novembre
à 80 ans l'enfant de narbonne n'a pas
perdu son humour en affirmant que ceux
qui viendront à son spectacle seront
dispensés d'aller à son enterrement
jean jacques dufour et frictions dorfer
sont d'ores et déjà dispensés
et ben arfa 6
brad boulangerie
la maison beaulieu ma mère ma tante et
laroche et espère pourtant que
reste-t-il de nos amours
dix de ces beaux jours une photo vieille
photo de ma venue
e
restez appuyé 12 des mois d'avril
les rendez vous un souvenir
thibault poursuit
sausset
revenons en france
sherwood roland
ce
merci de temps